[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom provide where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm joined by
my co-host dr. Greg Sadler and today
we're talking about technology and the
good life and this is going to be a
broad broad topic right yeah it's kind
of everywhere in our lives at this point
and it kind of hits on basically the
whole gambit of philosophy from you know
ontology to epistemology to ethics
it is the full gambit and we're only
going to be scratching the surface here
yeah and so we'll probably have to do
additional shows about other facets of
this so if you're listening and you
particularly enjoy one of the
discussions that we're having you might
want to send us a line and say hey let's
let's have some more of this but like
like like you were just saying yeah it
pervades everything I mean nowadays we
tend to say oh yeah the Internet is
everywhere but technology for human
beings is our natural way of existing
it's it's not as if there's ever been a
time when we didn't have any technology
going on right hey I mean we could say
that there was but were we even fully
human back then right you know one of
the the markers don't know if it even
holds up in anthropology any wars only
we are the tool-making animals even
though we now seated that to a couple
others as well yeah they used to say
homo Faber which can be translated as
the human being as the Smith or the the
crafter right and you know it all
Falcons we are yeah and it's interesting
in in in philosophy there was a
recognition already back in the modern
period that technology is not just tools
and artifacts that we have that language
itself is a type of technology so
Rousseau talks about this in some of his
discourses for example yeah one of the
the main things that makes us
predator or the top species and the plan
is our ability to really organize well
and do things in groups that would never
been able to owned by even small groups
of tribes you know up to maybe 200
people and one of the ways that we do
that is to have these stories and you
can't really have good stories without
really good language yeah that's that's
that's quite true and so language is
actually a good place to start with this
one of the bits of information I wanted
to bring into the conversation right
away as well where does this word
technology come from and as it turns out
it has its start not as technology but
as you can say technologists with
Aristotle who complains in his art of
rhetoric techne is is the word that he's
using there for art that the people
before him we don't have any of their
textbooks the textbook writers the
techno logo were only attending to one
aspect of rhetoric they were only paying
attention to what he called pathos
meaning emotion so they would tell you
like how to get people riled up or how
to get them scared or how to get them to
feel desire and then you would get it's
sort of a stimulus response right you
get them to feel the emotion and then
because they're feeling the emotion
through your use of language they will
have the output that you want like
they'll I mean suppose you could use it
for selling widgets but he also I think
used it it's talked about it you know
using it to start Wars or end Wars or
pick whatever you like and so technology
early on means something that you can
use as a set of techniques to get
something done this also the whole idea
of like lights kind of also comes back
to was it playdough of Socrates there's
really anti reading or like writing
things down ante writing yeah yeah and
the reason was because he said that it
would make us less able to use our
memory effectively and that's kind of
true you know to a certain extent but
like how much more could you have at
your fingertip
if you have a library in front of you
than trying to commit the entire library
to memory perfect yeah that's that's
quite true I mean think back to like
when we were kids and you'd have to do
your math class and the teacher would
say don't use a calculator you know
you've got to learn how to do it on your
own and one of the things that they
would say is you're not always gonna
have a calculator with you nowadays we
do though yep always
yeah I actually forced myself every once
in a while when I'm doing calculations
to do them by hand so that I don't
totally lose the habits that I built up
and become totally reliant on my my
cellphone I try to always do the tip in
my head that's a good way to do it yeah
yeah there was this reminds me of you
know continuing on from this don't write
things down and how we have books now on
but with the our cellphones and the
basically the full knowledge of the
human race at our fingertips
you know if someone from a hundred years
ago were to have a conversation from
basically anyone with a cell phone from
now they couldn't actually see them like
they're separated by a sheet you think
that that person from now would be the
most intelligent person that they've
ever talked to you but they're really
slow to actually respond yeah it's
almost like a Turing test for a demigod
right you can't see them in the other
room but somehow they they know
everything right and so the idea that we
were becoming to a certain extent in
symbiosis with technology itself and
that our our cell phones our second
brains yeah you know that's that's an
interesting way to put it because it's
not just a symbiosis with the let's say
the platform the the technology itself
it's also a symbiosis with the vast
archive of stored information out there
then we kind of swim in when we when we
want to Mille say this though and then I
do want to come back to one other thing
about about Aristotle that I think is
important about technology I noticed
that my students who now we're talking
about no longer Millennials but the the
gen Z but this up the supply sets of
Millennials to they were supposed to be
the digital
natives that like new technology inside
and out and are totally comfortable with
it I noticed though that when it comes
to many platforms and many artifacts
they they only know it at a surface
level so what else well yeah and and and
you know Gen Z as well I'm not saying
that that boomers or you know Gen Xers
are necessarily whizzes all the time
either but the fact that we had to
become acclimated say to using mobile
technology or web platforms or stuff
like that often means that we recognize
what we need to know better than they do
so like when I'm when I'm putting
together a really great online course in
a course management system many of them
don't know how to use some of the basic
functions within it I have to show them
in class okay here's how you do this
here's how you do this and I you know I
didn't do that at first because I just
assumed since all the experts were
telling us that they know all about this
technology that they did and then I
would find out that they didn't know how
to do basic things you know there's
still that divide between those who are
curious and want to dig and those who
are just I'll take the things that are
most apparent and easiest to grab yeah
and you know culture is something that
we have to acquire through work you know
it's not something that we can just take
for granted because we belong to a
particular generation or you know
particular culture or anything like that
it's something that we you know the
German word for culture is building and
it's a nice way to talk about it because
it has this sort of you know connotation
of you have to build it up you have to
develop it it's their word for build
also very similar bauen so it's it's got
at least a couple letters the same but
it's not the same root you know coming
back to Aristotle one of the things I
wanted to bring up about technology is
technology a lot of people port rated
well it's totally value neutral and you
know you can do whatever you want with
it it could be used for great evil like
if you're an evil scientist and you know
the comic books but we can also do these
wonderful things for it so we can like
change the world to make it a better
place like all the commercials
tell us when they're for the big tech
companies Aristotle had something really
interesting to say about what we
nowadays call technology you know
Aristotle was from a slave Society and
he gets a lot of flack for saying that
some people are natural slaves and
that's a whole different discussion that
we could have it turns out that very few
people are natural slaves according to
Aristotle properly read but one of the
things that Aristotle did say that I
think reveals the promise of technology
he talked about the slave or the servant
being the in sold tool the the tool that
can actually like operate other tools
and then he said if a loom could weave
itself then we wouldn't have to enslave
anybody nobody would ever have to like
be in that power relation of having
somebody else telling them what to do
and you know all the other bad things
that go along with it now we live in
this amazing world that Aristotle if he
were to step into it be like holy you
know look at all this stuff that like
does things on its own you know you talk
to your phone and say hey Google or hey
Siri or and sometimes it actually gets
things right and Aristotle would say
well I guess you don't need a personal
assistance you know we don't actually
need people to I mean in the near future
we're gonna have like automated cart
that not just cars but over the road
trucking right so we're not gonna need
all these CDL drivers and I'm a problem
yeah and and there there's downsides to
that but but it's also you know a
profession that's kind of dangerous and
hard on people's bodies and doesn't pay
that well anymore so you know there's
this promise of like we're gonna have a
because of the technology that we have
we're gonna eliminate power relations
that that put people at disadvantages I
don't think that happens at all well and
and robot is I want to say it's Slovak
yep slave it's Czech yeah Jack and it
means slave exactly yeah yeah as well as
it kind of reminds me of going to the
Jewish tradition of the Golem Oh
you know you're right instructions on a
piece of paper nice again the goldens
head and it starts going and it does the
things but the question is at what point
in time do we need to have worry about
the rights of these automated systems at
what point do they can become so
sophisticated sophisticated yeah that we
need to actually think about them in the
way that we think about humans and so
now you're right back to the very
beginning of this problem about like
having a slave or not if you're talking
about Aristotle here yeah and and that's
where the world of speculative fiction I
think can be quite helpful think about
azimoff's robot series both Wolfert for
two reasons one is the you know Three
Laws of Robotics which maybe we'll
actually use who knows but then there's
also like the robot rights movement in
it and why can they have rights because
they're sentient but they're I mean you
know animals are sentient too they're
not just sentient they are self
referential ascension they're able to
take conditions exactly yeah yeah you
want to go really far flung go into
culture series oh yeah with a eyes that
are super sophisticated and doing I
think have rights right oh absolutely
there they're equal citizens on but
they're also significantly more
intelligent and so you're like why do
they keep around the humans but
apparently they like them I don't know
yeah I've only read a few of those books
but I have really enjoyed that oh
they're great as well as if you're have
any interest you try to figure out what
the heck Elon Musk is thinking read
those books it has sunken ships it's got
automation it has neuro laces it's got
on what's called simulations within
simulations with his own simulations all
these things that are kind of like off
the wallet he talks about they're all in
these books I'm like oh I see where you
got it
banks has been gone for quite a while
too yeah yeah in the late 90s
interesting you know I I wonder you know
this reminds me the word
totally off topic at this point but it
does tie in with technology you think
about William Gibson William Gibson's
Neuromancer and then the others in in
that that series Mona Lisa overdrive and
accountant zero that's right yeah so
they they they set out this world of the
early depiction of the internet and it
turns out things were completely
different than than what he imagined
there's no thing wireless yeah well and
and you know viruses don't work the way
that that he was portraying them and all
that but it was a very imaginative world
and they they interviewed him to ask him
well were you like you know an early
tech adopter and all that he's like I
don't like any of that stuff I stay away
from it I was just like pouring this out
of my imagination you know and it's you
know it's quite interesting to think
about how that those early those early
narrative constructs about what the net
was gonna be like shaped so many things
even though there by somebody who
willfully withdrew from quite a bit of
that technology see it's something I'm
Heidegger you wanted to share with us
yeah so Martin Heidegger and I think you
could look at other authors as well who
are saying similar things there's
there's a couple things from his ideas
that I thought are useful for thinking
about technology one was he points out
that that when we're using technology
were often not that aware of it and I
think this is an important lesson for us
we want to develop more awareness
he thinks that we typically he's as an
example of a hammer and a hammers of
Technology right we were using the
hammer we're nailing things along we're
everything's going great and then like
something gets screwed up like the
handle breaks or you know the heads you
know twists a bit now we look at it for
the first time and we do something very
similar with our other technology right
so right now you and I are using several
different bits of technology and almost
we're actually paying close attention we
don't care about it at all
as soon as something goes wrong we're
like what is happening with audacity or
what's going on with Google Google
sheets or what
pick whatever you want all the way down
to the stopwatch why do the stopwatch
stop and now we become curious about it
and start attending to it in a real way
I think he's completely right about that
and that means that we would need to try
to overcome that tendency and it's
always going to be to some degree
forcing ourselves to pay attention to
what is actually happening with the
technology that we're using so we're no
longer just like a fish swimming in the
the water we actually pay attention to
the water the other thing that he said
that I think is helpful and again many
other people have said things like this
as well is that there's a tendency when
we allow ourselves to be sucked into a
certain mentality with respect to
technology in looking at the world as if
it's all tech as if like people can be
understood as tech so you know you see
people saying things like oh you know
your operating system isn't isn't
working right you know talking about
somebody oh yeah thinking right and the
idea is well we'll just reboot you or
you know we use all of this metaphorical
ideas and language that pertains go
ahead throughout history
like we've always used the most recent
technological innovation as a way to
shorthand ourselves to understanding
there's great old like things of
clockwork humans and or like steam
engine and like right right from you
know you know centuries back in and like
whatever is to do so yeah it's just like
an engine or whatever yeah and every
time we advance in our technology our
new analogies become the newest
technology yeah and so so Heidegger
thinks that in the late modern period
were in a kind of dangerous situation
where we're too successful with our
technology where we could in fact think
that say the brain is just a big
computer or you know we can we can
reprogram society just like we would
reprogram a neural network or something
like that you know and he calls this you
know this conception of things
by a bunch of different names but one of
the terms that he uses is standing
reserve where we see things essentially
as mathematize Abal resources that we
can then in some way extract or mine or
exploit and and reconfigure in
homogeneous ways and I think that this
is you know we don't always have to use
heidegger's language with this but I
think that we do see a lot of people
within not just the tech industry I
don't want to make them into the the big
baddies in this but maybe let's say all
the other industries that use tech tend
to look at things that way and they tend
to promote that that view so think about
social media which is something we're
gonna be talking about shortly there's
there's a tendency I think to look at
other people in social medias if they
are resources to be exploited for views
clicks add revenue you know pick
whatever whatever you want and and to
some degree it's true but the danger is
that of reducing people to that and once
you reduce someone to non-human status
it allows you to do a lot of things that
would be abhorrent exactly yeah the more
that you can like yeah abstract away the
human the easier is for you to exploit
the human yeah so nice we started out
with this title technology and the good
life and you might say well where's the
good life in this so far right so part
of what we want to suggest is that there
are some temptations traps problematic
aspects about technology that we have to
be attentive to not to be social critics
and and you know cynics and say oh it's
all terrible you know we should go back
to when you know things were better
before people carried all those
cellphones around and we're looking at
them all the time you know pick whatever
other example you want right we Twilight
exactly well I think there's a lot of
varieties of love it lud Luddite ism
what do we say you know and what about
diaspora yeah and one Luddite might not
be satisfied with what another Luddite
so like I I'm cool with well we should
get rid of the cellphones and you're
like well you're gonna get rid of the
cell phone you should probably get rid
of the phone phone you know you're not a
real honey I mean it goes
eventually the the natural progression
of that I guess is being back in caves
again and you know maybe fires a
technology so we don't even use that and
then it's all over very quick right but
you know we want to have something
positive that we're leading towards when
we're thinking about technology as well
because technology does have all these
great potentials for making our our
lives better in in many ways and so I
see like in stoicism and also like
Brazilian ism and all the the virtue
ethics places there's definitely this
idea of it's not the the thing that's
insult is yeah it is the way that you
use it is the actual good thing here and
a lot of these technologies have
incredible uses but they also have these
downsides and you can use them for good
or bad and you need to know where the
pitfalls are and part of that is how do
you choose which things that you you are
capable of dealing with what you have to
know yourself but to a certain extent to
be able to find those limits for
yourself and to know what your ground
truth of what is actually good is in
order to use those who's tools properly
yeah that's that that's a great way to
put it and there's also a communal
aspect to it so if I'm too immersed in
technology and you're say my roommate
well you're probably gonna get pretty
immersed in technology as well so how I
do things on my own has implications for
for you for you know my fellow
colleagues children pick whoever you
want right so I guess when we talk about
technology we want to know like who does
it serve and what purposes do it serve
and also what do we
to keep for ourselves as humans or
rational creatures and what do we want
to offload on to that technology so
that's a good reminder what what values
do we have to keep in play and keep
coming back to what would you say is
most important we've got oh definitely
privacy seems to be a perennial one that
goes back and forth and you've got
autonomy is that controlling me or am i
controlling it and comes in to also
agency and am I making the actual
decisions for myself or I'm letting
something else take that and I know the
the social connections that we make and
how we deal with those in a really
hopefully positive way and if am I the
one making the decisions to make these
connections or is that something just
given to me yeah you know it's it's
interesting because you brought up the
Stoics I'm reminded of epictetus who not
only says that you know we should
distinguish between what's actually in
our control and what's what's not within
that sphere of control but but says if
you if you're trying to seek things that
are outside of your control like trying
to make a million dollars which is
possible to do but you know you've got
to do a lot of other things along the
way that you might might find a little
unsavory in many cases to do that you're
placing yourself sort of in servitude to
the thing that you're desiring but then
he also says if somebody else controls
the thing that you desire you become a
slave to them and I think technology
provides all sorts of ways in which that
can happen if if what I really needed we
were talking about this before the show
you know if I really need dopamine
rushes and Facebook can figure out how
to exploit that I'm I'm you know screwed
at that point right
yeah they I have been their power I
don't actually have much autonomy and we
could come up with a lot of other
examples along those lines as well yeah
so speaking of Facebook and dopamine can
cast you the idea of Skinner boxes
otherwise known as operant conditioning
chambers made famous by BF Skinner
that's the Skinner box which was
basically the original experiment if I
remember correctly is either a mouse or
a rat in a box there's a light the light
goes on and if the mouse hits a button
when the light goes on it gets a treat
yeah and and so it could get it to
always hit the button and it just like
train it and so you and but they
wouldn't able to actually detect the
dopamine levels in the mouse on when the
light goes on and it wasn't the they're
getting the treat they got them the
dopamine it was just the light going on
because it was expecting yeah you
created like a pattern right and you
have to eventually becomes a habit and
so you think of your phone and those
nice little you know jingling bells and
whistles and I sound so old your alerts
and the flashing lights are all like
things that are like very stimulating
they give you that dopamine hit it's
very similar to like a lot of how
casinos set up their things like lights
and pretty things and noises and sounds
that are designed specifically to on
keep you getting that little dopamine
hit and and staying there longer yeah
you know I think back to when I was a
kid and we had these games that from the
present perspective were just garbage
total garbage you know I think about the
Atari system and how pixelated and
blocky the games were and how primitive
they were and then the handheld games
that had buttons on them and little led
things like you get a football or soccer
pick whatever you wanted and somehow you
had to like use your imagination to see
like okay this is a this is a person
making a pass you know and and we would
sit there and play these that we play
those games until the battery ran out
why because there was exactly that same
sort of loop it doesn't even have to be
like a good game it can be some some
game that from the perspective of even
not just the present but like 15 years
ago
these games were awful
I mean there are people who play them
kind of in a retro way now you know to
get back into it but they weren't they
weren't really any good and they arcade
games are the same way too they think
about space invaders people would sit
there and pump quarter after quarter
after quarter into it you know so
there's definitely a game to it what's
that that's called a game loop oh ok the
main thing that happens is is the game
loop and it's like like Oh challenge
reward challenge reward you can put more
things into it but like that's kind of
like the basic idea
yeah and how you set that up in order to
get people to continue playing your
thing and so cellphones are great at
these like being conditioning and we get
these little dopamine dips they also
allow us this connection as we said to
detect to knowledge and to social
networks and whatnot but there also have
like lots of potential privacy down
sides like privacy concerns about your
data and some people think that they're
spying on you like Edward Snowden talks
about like he always whenever gets a new
cellphone and he comes in and he pulls
out the microphone chips yes he doesn't
I trust them you know as well see most
of them have GPS monitors and GPS chips
in there you know if the CIA 50 years
ago and say everyone in the world has a
phone on them that has a microphone and
a GPS chip yeah they would be elated and
that we just have them on us all the
time and if you proposed that to the
general populace 50 years ago they'd be
like there's austerity you know but
right you can say well you know it helps
you drive your car around or or check in
you know if you want to like be on
Instagram and tell people where you are
you know I was mayor of McDonald's exam
and it that was in like I was there
Foursquare yeah yeah
yeah that's I mean those are some some
great examples of problematic aspects
there you can also say that there's a
habit in just reaching for your phone
right I mean there's a lot of people who
can't
well they deal with anxiety that way or
whether it's you know like regular
anxiety about things or the social
anxiety of being in an unfamiliar place
one of the things they do is reach for
their phone start looking at it now they
feel a little bit better there's even
people who like pretend to look at it
and don't don't actually look at it oh
and there's also people with phantom
ringing they think it's vibrating in
their pocket and it's not actually I
guess I must be that way I've had that
happen to me yeah it's common and so um
Ken brings us to social networks yeah
and social networks are also this like
dopamine box of of constant trying to
keep you there and the early designs
were just like how do you keep the
people on the site and engage as much as
possible and that was is that why some
of the networks didn't work they they
died out they didn't do that well enough
you think yeah absolutely think so you
know and and Facebook definitely figured
out that that good loop of trying to
keep people there engaged constantly and
the whole idea was that they're trying
to you know sell more add some more time
the people were on the site the more
they could sell their ads for and the
more data that they could pull up and
now you know data is the new oil yeah
but that's a whole nother topic on but
the problem is that these same systems
that are designed that this have you
stay there as long as possible results
in really negative behavior and mental
states for those users yeah so something
that's I mean you could I don't even
know you can call it an unintended
consequence because maybe the big tech
companies knew about this and they're
like yeah we don't care you know but
you've got something that's happening on
the large system level that that affects
each of the people participating in it
if they if they aren't careful if they
don't adopt a more
oh we call it more vigilant attitude or
mindful attitude towards the technology
that they're using yeah and this comes
back to the main topic here it's like we
were talking about a lot of things that
seem to be negative but the idea is that
you need to be aware of these things in
order for you to actually make informed
choices about what you're going to be
doing you have to be wise in order to do
you know the temper the courageous thing
here so you actually may be her tail
these actions or or work within the
network and within a certain way all
right right I'm like for example
Facebook is really great for sharing
memes that express your political
opinions and denigrate other people who
you're opposed to but maybe that's not a
good idea maybe maybe that's very
reductionist yeah maybe that's maybe
that's you know a thing that feels good
at first but is actually bad for you if
you if you keep on doing that whereas
there could be other uses for Facebook
that could be much more positive right
and you know there's been lots of
studies out there totally conclusive but
of the increased polarization within our
country is at least partially could be
attributed to these social media that
have on at least in the past reduce the
amount of other people's political
opinions because if you see people that
are arguing with you then you're less
likely to stay on so the more that you
see it everyone agrees with you the more
that you want to be there oh yeah yeah
yeah and so a part of this also is that
like once they added that like like or
up vote and thing it really hijacks our
our social approval centers in our brain
and so it kind of comes back to you like
we developed as as these small tribal
groups and to be in the tribe is to live
if you're ostracize and you're yeah
kicked out then you there's a good
chance that you're gonna die without the
group and so in order to make sure that
you have that same feeling you to have
approval from the group and if you're in
a social media where everyone can see
you
everyone can give you immediate
reactions you oh I like that our dislike
that that will really quickly on tune in
what you think is acceptable for your
group but the group is you know could be
the entire internet and how can you know
if that is actually the group that you
want to be with yeah do you think it
makes any difference you know Facebook a
while back rolled out there you didn't
just have like you've also got you know
the heart the angry face the sad face
you know LinkedIn has a similar thing
where there's like five different things
instead of just the like you can do
celebrate curious and I don't remember
what the other ones are do you think it
makes it any difference or is that just
like variations on a theme I I want to
say it's just area assumes on a theme
like the same the main concept is still
there embedded I think Instagram
actually took away people liking like it
doesn't show you how many people liked
it anymore hmm which seems to be
counterintuitive to see most social
networks but yeah well yes cerium is an
interesting one because in a certain way
they have the worst users in this
respect they they will in order to get a
good shot they will do all sorts of
things in the outside world the non
digital world that they're taking
pictures of and then posting that we
would consider to be a bad behavior so
like there was there was some at one
time it was the thing to take pictures
of you in front of sunflower fields and
I heard this story at one point I think
on NPR about all these Instagram people
going out to sunflower fields and
essentially destroying the crops in
order to get good shots and it was
almost like a feeding frenzy you know
people out of control or at least
portraying themselves as being out of
control so they could engage in
antisocial behavior that they're you
know it not only affects other people
badly but I mean you think that's also
kind of damaging to your own character
to be so in need of the the perfect
Instagram post that you got to do bad
things you know yeah I think we should
leave the social networks behind and try
to hit on automation here ya know why
they
that particular topic what's so
important about that because of the
things that are coming down the pipeline
I think this is one that is going to
upend our society in the most salient
ways or the most you know overarching
ways you touched on the idea of
automated trucking earlier yeah and it
was it there's in many states are
actually the majority of the states
trucking is the number one profession
hmm as well as there is a whole other
network of on small towns in in the the
plains and whatnot that are basically
entirely dependent on the trucking and
the truck stops that service them and
once you get rid of trucking with humans
and you get rid of these service
stations and there's a whole like
section of our economy up to like ten to
fifteen percent of our economy that is
just gone yeah you know it's interesting
when you think about that those places
are also ways in which human beings
interact with each other you you know
you you drive in with your load you park
up somewhere you go take a shower go get
something to eat maybe see some people
chitchat with them you know at the
restaurant that's all going away I mean
there's so many other things that have
gone away I mean I'm old enough to
remember when you didn't pay at the pump
for gas when you had to go in and
actually interact with the human being
and then all of that came along and
we're like well this is really
convenient now I don't have to talk to
anybody and I don't have to like you
know count my change or anything I just
put the credit card in and now I'm out
of here this is so nice but it also
really reduced one major way in which
people interacted with each other
yeah and so like the automation is this
double-edged sword it has the potential
for incredible gains or has potential to
significantly curtail our freedoms as
well as our material wealth going
forward and there's a short story from
many years ago I read it like a decade
ago called mana which is a whole story
about
like the slow creeping in of automation
in AI on to basically all sectors of the
economy and there were two societies
that arose from this one society was a
very private property Corp sir
individuals own basically all the
automation all the property and everyone
else became basically technological
serfs yeah and you'd if you went below a
certain rating then you were
unemployable and you know basically had
to live on just the meters of substance
of limiting and and then there was
another society I think it's popped up
in Australia on where the automation was
basically owned collectively and
everyone got to use the fruits of the
automation labor and turn into a
post-scarcity society yeah and you know
you mentioned Ian banks earlier the
whole culture premise is that humankind
goes out to the Stars and we have this
post-scarcity Society for the most part
in in what's called the culture and then
there's always like the intersection of
that trillions and trillions of people
living in that that culture and then the
the rest of the the universe where
things are less predictable and you know
that's where the good stories actually
happened yeah and and now it's
interesting because when we think about
where we could be headed which which
utopia or dystopia do we want so a
post-scarcity society one of the dangers
of that well what the hell did these
people do do they sit around playing
games all day you know is it like what
Marc's depicted where you work for a
couple hours in the morning and then go
fishing and then I don't know study
something I don't remember exactly how
the quote goes but that was you know he
was depicting what things are supposed
to be like later on or Star Trek where
like you know you you try to pursue
exuberance or like I'm gonna pee part
sharply because then I get to explore
and well Starfleet Starfleet is
interesting because they're the ones
where like you
things happen right yeah the the messy
stuff whereas you get the idea and the
rest of the Federation yeah you work on
your thing and life is pretty easy
now I don't actually see us heading
towards that because of the Akane of
social organization that we have and so
it seems much more likely that like you
said those who own the robots they're
gonna make out great and then what do we
do with you know what do we do when we
hit 40% unemployment and we don't have
anything for these people to do they're
you know they're are they just gonna be
happy sitting at home playing video
games and eating chips or are they gonna
want to stir up stuff to have like a
feeling of being alive and I'm a little
bit worried about that myself I believe
yeah a long time ago so I don't remember
it that well tell say why it's it's a
basic idea they just automate all the
factories and there are certain people
who are engineers who basically are run
maintenance on the factories and and
then everyone else is giving like a
really subsistence lifestyle yeah like
this baby but no one has any purpose and
so then they they rise up to destroy the
automation but immediately go back to
you automating after they destroy the
automation
yeah there's kind of a cycle too right
yeah I mean we see a similar thing when
people are railing against technology
they they often use some sort of
technology to do that so I guess the
question is like what is the pursuit of
a good life this is the person of the
good life more material things or is it
something else and can as long as like
there's definitely like we we gain some
I don't know a prestige from like doing
special and great things in competing to
a certain extent but does that have to
be in a means or a monetary or like you
know social status yes or but social
status was something I think would still
maintain especially like great artists
have social status but it's no longer
than just the
whoever can make the most money now how
social status yeah so technology in the
in a sense of automation and and all the
other things that go longer that AI
logistics you know all these things
converging together is threatening you
know in ways that we can't quite wrap
our head around I suppose yeah this is
this is this is what Gabriela Marcel
called human beings being at the mercy
of their own technics you know kinda
well it's it's similar to Heidegger's
view that when we when we it's not just
a mindset that we have we actually do
create the technology and then the
mindset and technology kind of go
together and they they assume more and
more forward inertia you could say and
at a certain point we we lose not just
oversight but actual control over where
things are going and and I think this is
facilitated by all the people who are
like tech optimists who are like Oh
technology's gonna make everything
perfect and and everything's gonna be
wonderful they don't know what they're
talking about most of the time they're
selling us this line you know I mean can
we really rely on Google to follow it's
it's 1/8 achill principle of don't be
evil I don't think so so go ahead this
reminds me of a basement code and so
basically code is a term for that code
which no one had knows what the heck
does really anymore
oh really might know what it does but
they don't know how it does it
who made it is long gone and if you try
to remove it everything breaks or if you
try to like edit it at all everything
breaks and and look at most of our
banking system in the United States it's
all built on COBOL servers which is an
ancient language on like in technology
terms it was you know it's 60 years 70
years old at this point in time and it's
it's rather slow
and it's rather arcane in its the way
it's written and if we didn't have those
servers running this ancient cold our
entire economy would run to a halt
immediately yeah yeah and and you know I
think things are at the point where
nobody can really understand even the
like cutting-edge codes that they're
using
nobody can totally wrap their head
around what they're doing well I don't I
don't mean just like the project that
they're working on yeah though the
entirety of yes yeah and then you also
have AI are not machine learning
specifically which is a subset of AI
well yeah it's a black box it's it's the
little dark secret of computer science
is that that you can't go and just
change the line of code in a machine
learning matrix and yeah our neural net
and and usually we retrain things you
don't know exactly why these things do
it but we know it works and it works
reliably yeah so there's a pragmatic
motif there right yeah and we're getting
a lot better at like poking the box and
give me introduce more and better things
more reliably but to go in and like know
how exactly it is doing it is not well
well Noble and it's interesting and I I
think the learning and machine learning
is really metaphorical but if we want to
go ahead and use that term I think we
also have to say that whatever machine
learning is taking place that we're
seeing there's also all sorts of other
learning that were not conscious of and
we won't see the effects of until like
you know we're in a new situation and
suddenly the AI starts behaving in a
very different but probably in some
respect creative way that we might not
entirely like right so you know and I
mean there's all sorts of great
speculative
work about this where you know like the
computer realizes that we human beings
are rather inefficient and you know
maybe we should get them out of the way
or you know modify it up in certain ways
you know predicts what our paper clips
exactly well it were desire you know it
knows what our desires are better than
we do at least it thinks it does and
then there's nothing we can do about it
I mean this is we're getting pretty far
afield how do we bring this back to like
the day-to-day existence that we have so
that we can keep using the technology
that we we have but do it and more so
kind of looking at this going back to
automation specifically because that
stopped we're on on and I do want to
plug that the short story man is by
Marshall Brian but it kind of makes me
think of the rauzein theory of justice
and is specifically his idea of maxi min
and so the idea is that if you were to
create a society I'm he believes that if
people didn't know what position within
the psy.d society that would make they
would make a society in which the lowest
person on the society had the maximum
material wealth basically and so it
doesn't mean that everyone had to have
the same a material wealth there could
be certain people that had lots more
wealth than others but only if that
produced a society in which the minimum
level had a the highest amount of
minimum yeah so saying that you know
brings to mind the idea that's been
kicked around quite a bit recently and I
I'm kind of hoping we someday see in our
future of a universal basic income now
some people I mean there's always people
how are you gonna pay for that well I
mean stop having as many wars may be
pretty easy to do right it's not we
could probably route out some government
corruption and pay for it quite easily
as well but there is one objection that
people bring up that I think is I don't
buy it but I think it needs to be
engaged and here's how it goes so if you
give people a universal basic income it
needs to be something good it can't be
just a thousand bucks a month because
what can you do with that in our society
right I mean spend more than half of
that on rent probably where we live so
let's say it's you know it's quite
generous then aren't people just going
to become lazy and complacent and
expected as a dole and won't it lead to
a society which is stratified into those
they'll still be those who like own
everything but there'll be those who
work to support everybody and then
they'll be those who just live on the
dole and their lives won't be all that
productive and and that's not good for
them and it's also not good for others
because it increase it creates
resentments and you know what what do i
I think there's good answers to that
what do you think is a good answer to
that good answers like the alternative
is we have on nation we have 40 to 60
percent of the population without jobs
and would you rather have 46 percent of
those people with no jobs and are hungry
and are riding the streets and
destroying everything or do you want to
make sure that everyone is like at least
healthy and well fed so this is sort of
one of those let's not that let the
perfect become the enemy the good sort
of things right right yeah do you have
any others I don't I don't think that I
kind of hope that although there will be
some people who would just take
advantage of it and basically do nothing
all day I kind of think and hope that
there would be a lot of people who would
use that time and you know freedom from
fear to work on themselves to to engage
in study of whatever it is that's going
to make them have a valuable life and to
engage in social interactions with other
people that aren't driven just by
worries about money or social status or
whatever other you know limited goods
we're going to have it I mean it would
be something I don't I I don't envision
a complete post scarcity society like
we've been talking about but I think we
could get closer to it
that it would be better for people to
have that flexibility
I also think maybe then people would be
interested in studying stoicism not to
like deal with how crappy their lives
are and insulate themselves but to make
genuine progress towards the human good
you know we should talk since there's
bringing up practice we should talk
about a practice that we had in mind
before we jump into you know final
thoughts so you you when we were talking
about this before you had some worries
about recommending an app as a practice
well what was that worry so the idea is
like if you are having something do it
for you you're automating your practices
away then are you actually working to
improve yourself and I think we came to
the conclusion that if you only and
forever use that as a crutch to do this
and that's probably not the way to go
yeah but if we actually do recommend app
and that allows us to grow and as
training wheels to be able to be more
resilient than that would be okay
yeah and so there's there's a lot of
apps out there that are in one way or
another oriented towards various
practical philosophy the stoicism has
become quite popular so there's some
stoicism apps out there that'll give you
like quotes and some meditation
practices and allow you to do some
journaling and I'm always leery of those
like because I want to do things on my
own
but but I think that like you're saying
if you're if you're using it as a tool
and you keep in mind that it is a tool
and you use it to try to also grow your
own self rather than just becoming more
and more dependent on the app it seems
like that that's a good way to do things
and it could lead to personal growth
developing new habits maybe we with a
social function you can even say
connecting up with other people who
would support you in in that work
so I see a lot of potential there for
intersection between what Foucault
called the technology of the self all
these ways in which ancient philosophy
would work on and redevelop the self
towards you know genuine happiness
autonomy all these things and what we
typically call technology meaning
external technology I think those could
work together well but one would have to
constantly be attentive and like assess
every so often am I am I getting too
invested in the app you know my too
reliant on it you know what are you I
think that's a really good way to look
at it and so one of the ones that I have
is a I I tend to read too much political
news and there's so much of it and you
can just kind of go but down I call the
clickhole and yes constantly reading and
reading or you know look there's a new
link and so I have a app on my phone I'd
actually I think it's built into the
Android system that makes us you can tap
open an app unless you go through some
hoops basically and one of the hoops is
that it it only gives you like 5 10 or
15 minutes to open the app and then it
closes the app and so it gives you a
time to change your context and so one
of the things that we didn't quite get
on to was the idea of infinite scroll
and how yes is a potential psychological
trap because there's no longer a point
where you're changing to a new page and
that is usually a really good way for us
to mentally breakup from one section to
another kind of like walking through a
door in a house yeah and and then move
to different contexts it's funny the
context stretching is another term in
and computer science but what does that
mean
so context switching is in an operating
system is the piece of program that
allows for all the other programs to run
on top of it and so each individual
program thinks
has access to the direct computer
basically that's the lease how it or
it's originally set up and and so on it
gets they get put into on ram memory
useful volatile memory and uh and they
get paused and then you switch to a
different computer different on
application and then that pauses and
this is another application so that we
absolutely one application to
application three it will switch back to
the first one the first one thinks that
it's never stopped it was like i'm
continuously running uh because it
doesn't have the ability to know
anything outside of itself the operating
system thinking that says you run and
then you run and then you run but it
does it so fast gigahertz you know
millions of times per second I'm sorry
billions of times per second that it
doesn't matter that these all these
programs you know we have our video shot
we've got audacity and whatnot all set
up that they all think that they're
continually running and the operating
system is constantly churning through to
make sure that everything has enough
compute power in enough amount of time
and that's contacts it's almost as if
the operating system is dealing with a
whole bunch of almost solipsistic
narcissists yes absolutely that's
interesting so how does that apply here
okay thanks watching context which is
usually just how we change what we are
focused on and so you know I'm focused
right now really intently on this
conversation with you and then a little
bit on the the timer over here counting
down yeah and and going back to the idea
of the actual practice is that this
timer this timeout allows us to stop on
and allows us to back out out of our
phones which can be very addictive and
as use that as training wheels see like
oh I should only have be on my phone
or maybe five or ten minutes that time
but I'm sitting there for like an hour
then I definitely been on this device
for much longer than utility would
actually dictate yeah I mean I like that
idea because it means that there's a
calling attention to the fact that we
have a choice that we have some agency
there an agency is one of those things
that unless we exercise it we lose it
right well we're just about out of time
any last thoughts that you have we don't
have I don't think we have a a final
quote although we could certainly talk
about this danger of you know becoming
the prey to our technology you know
almost like The Sorcerer's Apprentice
who starts up the magic and then it just
takes off without them or the works of
Isaac Asimov any technology sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
arthur c clarke oh yes oh that's that's
a fitting thing to go on
[Music]
you
you